and the winner of relationship goals is
judge
[Music]
welcome to relationship goals i'm theo
johnson your host and i'm with one two
funny this guy is gonna be the judge
jewellery and executioner relationship
goals is a tournament where coppers go
head to head to see who's got the most
solid couple if they win this they go to
the semi-final if they win at the
semi-final they go to the final and if
they win the final
jordan ruby
even though this money you know
but more importantly as my judges
demonstrated they win a hundred free
firewave pizzas
and whoever wins just know about me and
them was friends from time to go i'm
saying let's hope
to get that bag you know we wiped the
floor with the last cup you know i'm
saying yeah
yeah let's see what we can unlock in
this episode we are back
and yeah so we beat the other couple was
easy we're here for the win big w's big
money i'm nigel man i want the money
today you understand please we do not
need it yeah arms oh yeah you're not
gonna handle the smoke bro you don't
know each other like how we know each
other what i'm saying we know each other
like this
you guys are gonna break up after this
show man it's gonna be a joke thing i'm
telling you you squeaked on the loose
you said we're gonna break up
well we're a solid couple like no cat
we're a solid couple so we're gonna win
welcome back to relationship goals i'm
theo johnson your host and i'm still
with my judge a12 funny and we are
finally at the finals
first and foremost congratulations for
getting this far this is the finals
one step closer to that bag but now
in order to pass the final test we need
to test your strength as a couple we
need to test your intelligence as a
couple we really need to see how much
you really know each other so this is
what the rounds are going to consist of
so firstly could you get in the arm
wrestle position please amanda and or
jenna come on clasp hands please see
them biceps flexors
okay
[Music]
okay
oh
all the guys out there with small inches
it's your day
both of you showed great strength
both of you showed great grip
but oyena you took the win and now
you'll be awarded with the first three
points of today congratulations
congratulations thank you you shocked me
oh yeah yeah you weren't you're she's
scared yeah you see him
you know
you actually seemed scared
at the start
she was getting in your head she wanted
to make you think you had it you guys
good luck good luck three
two
one
as you can see oh and it's been
i thought he's had the other distance
bicep basket later
let's move arms locked around
two
[Music]
all right guys welcome to round two
this is a class to determine your
knowledge of each other
i'm gonna ask you guys a personal
question which you should know about
your misses she's gonna then write it on
a paper
press the buzzer and reveal the answer
and then use that are gonna say that
answer as soon as you hear the buzzers
first question
what is your girlfriend's star sign
leo
okay well yeah there we go question two
what's her favorite song
what activity
[Laughter]
that's another point question
three
what is her middle name
louise
hi i'm going to give it to them because
you actually said the answer before she
pressed no she pressed it i'll wait for
the for the thing i generally do wait uh
i can't leave it okay
i'm gonna go with
all right cool
do you know the answer
five
four things three
two
one
and that has now gone to amanda's team
my brain blank i'm not gonna lie damn
that's nice before so
they are for no reason later
louise
i can confirm that is correct louise
he's okay
fine
he's okay we don't know your girl's
middle name pressure got this okay
let's see who gets the answer to this
one see there's everyone so cocky out
here
how much does your girlfriend weigh
we haven't cheated yet buzzer what is
the answer
10.7 stones
yeah we can confirm it is 10.7 question
four
what is your girlfriend's
shoe size
ain't cheated yet you are bad at this oh
yeah man you are very poor at this
i'm gonna have to go for four you know
it's between four and five so i'm going
to save two and four and five yeah i've
got four in
four okay i can reveal the answer is
actually three
that's one you should know mate i know
you've never bought your girlfriend it's
three since when does it fall the
question gets passed over
four
okay so we have swap places so ladies
it's your time to see how much you know
about your partner okay for question one
who is your boyfriend's
favorite rapper
okay
go on
arms a little nervous at your paper
little dough
not fashion speak to you right now
oh you follow asap rocky for fashion
yeah just for fashion but music little
dirt yeah
swing get back over to this side
keep waiting for the night he wizzy
thank you wizzity whiz
question two
what is your boyfriend's
biggest fear
we're gonna go with yes
the sea water
nothing you put nothing yeah but what
was your answer
the ocean the sea why because you can't
swim oh she just outed you like that you
know but can you swim no
that's why i went together i guess oh
okay hey you can't swim
these are doing titanic you know i did
say they're gonna break up by the end of
this just mark my words bro i did say
this wow basically said you're drowning
pardon the pun
okay
what
is your boyfriend's favorite film
i'm gonna go with hasn't cheated yet
dark knight
the dark knight hey i don't know i
didn't say that one of the last weeks i
didn't say hey all right mate yeah cool
blimey
what age did your boyfriend lose his
virginity
oh that was a tough one you know that
was that was definitely them trust they
need it anyway you know okay
okay five
four
[Music]
wow one point congratulations guys wow
okay okay all right
what is your boyfriend's
shoe size
yes
we're gonna go with nash
five
four nine
correct enough to sing over here
what is your boyfriend's
favorite color
yes red
nice one
okay the crepe the crepe the last point
again grab the last one and you said
that with confidence i like that so
the judge has done the count
and i can now confirm
that the scores for round two
are
ten points
till later in amanda
and six points
to oh yeah and arms he's funny you
sounded like he said to leighton and the
man
[Laughter]
no
[Music]
so this is round three the general
knowledge round i use like feeling
knowledgeable yeah okay so you've got 60
seconds to answer as many questions as
possible if you don't know the answer
just say pass if you know the answer
perfect if you answer and it's wrong
the timer will stop and it will go over
to amanda relay and do you understand if
they get the answer right one of your
answers will be striked off and you will
lose that point all right can i start
the timer please
what year was fireway pizza founded past
2016. what is the time difference
between london and paris 100. correct
what does bbc stand for british
broadcasting
that is wrong can we stop the timer
amanda and leighton what does bbc stand
for big black obviously
[Laughter]
let's go who's the owner of amazon jeff
bezos correct who's the fastest person
in the world usain bolt correct how many
senses are there
five correct
how many colors are there in a rainbow
seven correct
where was peter pan from
neverland
which princess had seven doors
no way correct
what animal is on the porsche logo
jaguar
incorrect stop stop the timer please can
i say oh horse
correct
strikes finish the sentence a leopard
never changes it's
what
spots yeah correct lady our you that did
pretty well there
i'm pleasantly surprised i thought you
was gonna do poorly anyway
well done
guys
how are you feeling you ready to swap
over yeah
okay are you guys ready yeah yep
harms
jenna are you ready yeah what year was
the battle of hastings
what's the name of mr crab's daughter
correct who plays joy in what happens in
vegas pass
what country is valenciaga from
where did eminem grow up
detroit how many subscribers does
standout tv have
passed what's the name of the cowboy in
toy story
woody correct who sings find me in the
club
who says man's not hot
big shot correct who's the main
character in wolf of wall street
leonardo dicaprio yeah
i'll give you that one because he's not
saying
all right guys so this is the end of
round three well done i'm pretty
impressed use that got real competitive
close to the end and
you edged it by one point there's
literally one point between you it's mad
so
the points have been counted and i can
now reveal
that the scores are
and the winner of relationship goals is
judge
drum roll please
amanda
[Music]
this has been relationship goals amanda
and layton will be going away with a
thousand pound and a hundred free fire
away pizzas
i've been phil johnson your host and i'm
with my judge hey want you funny join us
in season two
stay safe
stay loyal
we only lost by one point so to be
honest like it doesn't mean
yeah like i would rather get beaten like
obliterated rather than lose by one
point are you gonna spend a thousand
pounds on
she well amanda thinks it's gonna be a
lv bag but it's gonna be for me and i'm
saying because obviously i clutched it
back in the last round you know i'm
saying without that
we've only got that wrong bag you know
i'm saying said that we was going to win
we delivered we are the man and woman of
our world you know i'm saying well they
didn't break up in the end but hey ho
they did do well i just know that our
relationship is strong so yeah
obviously we're gonna win well we know
we'll be back we know we're a strong
couple so
we are relationship goals
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you